It was so bad that the judge made him delete all video and evidence
and every picture he had of things that he took when she didn't
want it, of times that he grabbed her and forced her to suck
his times that he made her do things she didn't want to do and
times that she didn't want to be recorded. >> A little
bit in there. >> The judge said, "Delete everything about
Pingchu on your phone or I'm going to try you for criminal charges."
>> That he is ordered to remove and delete and get rid
of all pictures and videos without her permission. And even with
or he will face criminal charges. He is forced to pay her attorney
fees around $50,000. The protective order is for 10 years. Chad,
you I don't think a lot of you understand how crazy it is to
get a protective order. That means that when Tekon goes on planes,
he has to do something that it's going to follow Tecton for the
next 10 years of his life. It is serious.
before I even go public with the things that I have right now.
And by the way, this is not everything. I'm going to let you
guys know what I have was written down. Uh I wasn't there. So
don't say this is from me. This was not from me. This is from
Axian. I sent Axi in there and Axian went and wrote down notes
for 7 hours and wrote things down to and told me. I'm not going
to lie, a lot of court can be pretty [__] boring.
So Ashton was bored as because sometimes they just do things
for like 30 minutes where they just, you know, have to like have
someone sit up and sit down. But he wrote down a lot of the good
facts about what happened. Yes, it was Axi. He went um Yes.
Dad, his dad went to jail in 2011. He went on TV for it. Teone
used to get bullied apparently in school. People tweeted at him
for years about this, but Teetone claims he didn't know. Lies.
You didn't know that your dad had this rap allegation. Your dad
was this big bad wolf. I do not believe it. You were not young,
Teeone. You were 17 years old. You can't pretend you didn't know
what was happening. I'm sure you went to the court cases. I'm
sure you saw what's happening. And I guarantee you your friends
looked this up if you wanted to pretend that you thought your
dad was your idol and you didn't see it. You don't think your
friends in high school would have looked this up and told you
what's going on or someone in your class would have talked about
how the fact that it was on TV. fault. >> You 100% knew.
Stop acting like you didn't know that your dad was a weirdo.
And even if you want to pretend that tech tone and act like you
didn't know. Hm. Why would you bring over your dad to Amaru,
someone that you call your close friend in Asminold when you
know that he was abusing you when you were younger? I wouldn't
bring my dad around anyone that was abusing me. Let alone the
fact that you brought him around Emiru when you said that he
thought she was hot.
You weirdo. You're a disgusting man just on that. But let's go
on to what you really are. Abusive. And you assault your uh partners
and it the the word abusive is tame compared to what you are.
Techone. You're vile. You're a vile vile man.
>> Teone
uh Teone
was abusive towards Frame. Frame and him dated since they were
like 20 years old. They d they dated and then they got married.
The reason why they got married is they wanted to have to be
able to move to America and they also did it for tax reasons.
Whatever. They got married. I don't really care what the reason
was. Um, TeeOne also claimed that his father held a gun to his
head.
You held he held a gun to your head and you brought him to your
podcast with your close friends Amaru and Asmin. You would bring
him on stream and promote him when he held a gun to your head.
So, Free accused him of abuse. Uh, you saw that video. Free accused
him of abuse and that he was uh constantly abusing her. I don't
know to what extent the abuse was. He would buy her her clothes.
He would buy her things. And Frame accused him of assault and
abuse. Tech was very controlling. And I like how when I say I'm
controlling, it's more so like, oh well, I would just didn't
like how she wore stuff. It wasn't really controlling. It was
just I had boundaries and it picked me off. But he really controlled
what she would wear. He would tell her and buy her bras. He would
buy her things and tell her to wear it around the house. He abused
her and assaulted her. Okay. They settled outside of court for
$30,000
and F basically said that he's in a terrible person. He is not
she's not okay with him and she went silent. >> I don't
I don't >> during that time immediately left and went on
to Pinkchu, a small content creator who didn't have a voice and
didn't know what was going on in the slightest. This girl was
innocent and on Instagram just doing [__] Only Fans
and cosplays. That's all she was doing. >> Okay.
He started dating Pinkchu and immediately made everyone assume
that Teone uh was the bad uh was the the the guy that was getting
accused of everything and he did no wrong that Fe actually cheated
on him and that Fe is saying these terrible things like he abused
her and assaulted her when he didn't do anything. Pinkchu thought
that that was true because she didn't know FM. She didn't know
the situation and he she thought that uh Fe was sending and doing
disgusting things by leaking that Pink Chu was there and saying
that you are harassing me and Tee. She sued Teone. Why did she
sue Teone? Because Teone told her to. Because Teone manipulated
her into doing it, thinking that you're she's a terrible person.
>> She would he would tell tech uh her what to say, what
to do, what to wear. >> And it worked. and he used pink
to make the attention to make people look insane. So that way
if anything ever came out, >> you guys would go, "Wow,
Frame's
>> And then he can just lock it away with a $30,000 NDA
and call it a day. And then he could just do the same thing to
Pink, which he did. So he didn't learn from his first human degenerate
just again. >> He literally went Tech Family Tree is a
literal actual infinite Rick machine
>> about it. Cuco knew about it and she was going to put
out a Google doc about Teone, but then he settled it outside
of >> So, there was proof. People knew
>> and they settled outside of court.
>> Dated Pingchu. >> He used her for years. He used
uh her to make people to think that Fe was insane and he sued
her. Free settled outside of court. Pingchu. Then the abuse began
for her.
And it's bad, Chad. I'm warning you if you don't like this kind
of you should leave. It's gross what I'm about to reveal. And
I want to see these guys like this kimchi guy on Twitter, whatever
the his name is, try to defend Techone after what I'm about to
show you right now. Okay.
>> show it, show it, show it. >> Pink realized who
he was and Pink sued
>> Pink sued Teone for assault and abuse. And she first
went public, which people called her an only fans Tecton's friends
all [__] on him her relentlessly and Teone continued
to berate her for years. Okay. He bered her for years and said
that everything she's saying is lies and not true. And Pink just
sat there and just continued to live with this for 2 years that
everyone was on their her side for years because he went around
all of Austin and told everyone that she was the problem and
she was a and she's making this up. And since Frame was already
gone with an NDA, people believed Teto because they didn't really
know Pink. So Pink was ostracized in Austin for a long time until
people started to like her and realized that techone was the
problem. Pink was abused and assaulted a horrible >> and
she won her court case yesterday. She didn't just win her court
case. >> All legal things have to all legal things have
to be paid for. And Teone has to have a 10-year protective order.
That means that Teetone cannot have guns. He cannot have weapons
in his house. That's why he deleted his tweet yesterday. He can't
have weapons, period. Also, what he had in his phone was so damning
and disgusting about Pinkchu that he was ordered by the court
to delete it immediately or he'll be tried for criminal charges.
Well, that's I mean
kind of what we expected, right? >> I'm going to go through
some of the things I have today. The reason why I'm not going
to go through all of it is because I'm going to wait for the
transcripts and I'm going to continue to leak this very slowly
so that way I make sure that everyone can see it because I get
today ice stuff happened and the raid happened. I get it. >> I
understand >> you're going to react to that. You don't
want to react to tech. I'll make this a fiveday special just
like you did with
>> So, the reason why I hate TechOne,
okay,
is >> I'm back to the list. One, I hate that he did this
and he's disgusting. Two, he's vile to everybody around me and
I'm vile in general and I've known he's a massive liar for years.
Tech said he that I said he likes VTuber gota games and I made
a joke. I apologized and he continued to attack me for it years
later because he was mad that I was dating Amaru. That's it.
He was mad I was dating Emmy. He hated I dated. He was obsessed
with her. He wanted to date her. He literally was always talking
about her to Pinku and everyone else. Um, but I didn't really
that didn't really phase me. I didn't really care that much.
Uh cuz he's a bald ugly loser who literally just sits there and
has no muscle mass and his cortisol levels are through the roof.
He said I made him made him pay $300,000 for a loan and charged
extra, which is completely false. He would tell this to his stream
all the time that I made him pay $300 for a loan and charged
extra. Just to let you know, I made Tee pay me $300,000 for a
loan that I gave him. I gave Teone $300,000 because I liked him
at the time four years ago and I thought he was cool and I wanted
him to live near me and I wanted to help OTK.
Teone accused me of basically using him uh throwing him away
and that I would make him pay fees on top of it, making his community
and as Gold's community hate me. This is completely false. I
had him pay $5,000 in fees uh on the podcast afterwards for a
$300,000 loan, which by the way, that's 1.3% interest or something
like that. Wow. I gave him the cash in cash in in just a week
because I wanted to have him live near me because I thought he
was going to be my friend and join OTK. Teone kept paying me
like a with PayPal
who takes fees. So, Teone kept paying for fees like a and blamed
me for that.
Techone hated me because I was dating
>> True. He liked Emmy and he hated I was dating her. Him
and his dad would say weird allegedly, which is what Pinkchu
claimed and I totally believe her. He hated me because Russell
threw a pool party in my backyard one time and that's when I
first met his girlfriend Pinkchu.
Um, and I think TeeOne was probably afraid that I'm going to
take her away from me because I shook her hand
and he went around Austin and he did everywhere telling people
that I grabbed her hand for such a long period of time and it
was so weird and told everyone I'm weird as for that and made
people believe me.
he made people believe me that I was weird. He even told Emaroo
about it. He told every everyone that I was weird and that I'm
aggressive and I'm I'm a weird dude for holding her and grabbing
her hand and I was trying to be touchy when literally Pink Chu
messaged me a year later was like that never happened and I'm
so sorry that he went around. She didn't know that that was even
>> This is Pink Chu by the way. >> He said I'm the
reason why he got kicked from Only Fangs.
>> This is completely false. He said he hates me for this
the most. She made the decision and it was unanimous by everyone.
This is when Pingchu came out with her allegations and his dad
got considered a serial.
Yeah, buddy. Nobody wants you and only thanks. Nobody.
I literally just messaged Chance and said, "What are we going
to do about Techone?" Chance said, "I kicked him from the guild.
I showed you guys receipts yesterday of this. I have receipts
of everything I say."
Okay. What I'm about to show you
is written down by Lucari or by not Lucari by Axian
um of notes
and this is an exact written down thing of a small piece of what
went on yesterday. Okay. >> Oh, this is the transcript.
Not the transcript, but this is a piece of it. Okay. Keep in
mind it was an eight hour thing. He didn't write eight hours
of non-stop notes. he would be his hand would not be working
right now. But he wrote down pieces of it. I'm not showing it
all at once because I want to keep this and keep this going because
I want everyone to know how vile of a person Tech Tone is and
I want to make sure that every content creator who pretends to
watch this right now because the ice is going on. >> He
showed the Shimu video. Okay. >> All right. You ready?
Hold on one sec.
[snorts] ready.
this. So, when I'm when I'm going over this, I want to let you
guys know that this is uh Pink's lawyer who is speaking
and this is Techone. Okay.
>> this is Techone.
Uh
>> get Axian in a call. Sure.
Do we
quick question? Did Axian steal Pikachu show shoes? Okay, I that's
what I need to know first. >> All right. All right. Can
I deal with this guy? >> Let's go through this. Okay. >> Did
he steal her shoes? >> I wrote this all down last night.
>> We don't deal with people like this. >> And I
can tell you what was said.
>> Okay. Axium was the one in court. All right. This is
This is Pink Choose lawyer. This is Pink Chu's lawyer. This is
Tech. All right.
Keep in mind Pink Choose lawyer was one lawyer versus five people.
She said, "Why would you tell her you can talk about your experiences,
which is this stuff, but my client cannot talk uh why would you
tell her you can talk about your uh your experiences, which Tech
would constantly talk about everything on stream, but my client
cannot talk about her experiences when she doesn't name you."
This refers to the tweet where Pinku says how terrible he was
and how he would grab her head and force her to suck his dick.
Okay,
move the chat to the right. Oh, and hold >> We're not blocking,
right? There we go. We are kind of blocking. Techie, GET GET
YOUR FAT HEAD OUT OF THE WAY. TECHIE Tone said, "Well, one, because
it didn't happen, and two, because everybody knew what she was
talking was about me." >> All right. And can you tell me
this if you ever make her write words on her face? Yes. And how
many times would you did you record her? Um, a lot. And how many
times did you tell her, "No, I don't want to be recorded." Never.
How many times did you actually agree to be recorded? every time
she'd hold the camera and tell me this. You made a reference,
I hope this is interesting, about how she tried to have a huh
conversation with you about non-consentual versus consensual
and it made you uncomfortable, so you didn't want to discuss
it. Oh, she said she would be okay with consensual non-consentual
because she was bored and didn't want to have intercourse.
>> That's a mistake. Uh, he didn't want to have intercourse.
>> Oh, he didn't want to have intercourse.
So, he was bored and didn't want to have
>> All right. And what did you have? >> He didn't
want intercourse. I'm sorry. >> Yeah. Yeah. He didn't want
to have he didn't want to have intercourse. Yeah.
>> So, he didn't want to have intercourse and that's why
he was okay. I didn't >> Wait for this.
>> Why did he Why do you think he didn't want to have intercourse,
chat?
But wait for this. All right. And what did you have her write
on her forehead? I have never had her right, but I h did have
her right come in here with an arrow pointing down. >> I'll
be honest. I don't know what Miskf is cooking here, but I'm I'm
here for it. Okay, I like the energy still. I'm Wait, was that
a punch line? Misg
Are you good?
>> Who cares? Kink shaming. She didn't want it, buddy.
She didn't want to do this.
And did you tell that she would uh that that she would you would
have a intercourse with her if she did this and have a normal
relationship? Never. No, that was just dressing up. >> So
basically she wanted to continue. She wanted to have a normal
relationship with intercourse. >> No, it's weird to tell
her if you keep doing this then one day we will finally have
intercourse. So they never had sex. He would just use her as
a quote [__]
Why wouldn't he want to have and force her to just have give
him head?
Why? I wonder why.
Why would you not want to have sex with her? She's she's an attractive
girl. Why would you just want head only?
And did you tell that she would uh that she that you would have
intercourse with her if she did this and have a normal relationship?
Never know. That was just dressing up. That's a degrading thing
to do to a woman. Is that correct? Oh, she would frequently cosplay
herself.
Oh, so she would frequently degrade
How does an outfit the same as writing derogatory statements
on someone's face uh m make sense and come here? I guess I didn't
really see it as degrading. And it was also kind of her idea
to make this things go on in the bedroom.
>> So, isn't so isn't that maybe the problem, Mr. Robertson,
that she views what you did as non-consensual and you just don't
see it that way? I think if I if I was ever informed a single
time that was wrong, I would immediately say, "Well, then let's
not do it." To be completely honest,
just wait, chat. Okay, but that's not true. You actually would
sit her down with a whiteboard and go over everything to convince
her that she was wrong.
I'm feeling to see how this two connect. But I don't understand
what you in regard have we we've talked about with the whiteboard
and you would sit down with her at the whiteboard and whatever
position she was taking. You were all disagreeing in on correct
if we were having an argument and not seeing eye to eye and we
weren't seeing eye to eye. Visual aid really helped her as well
as to me. This dude would pull out a whiteboard to explain why
she is wrong about consensual and non-consensual.
the X's and O's of consent.
>> He would have to bring up a whiteboard and say, "Oh,
the reason why is because she doesn't understand it." So, I have
to visually show her and explain it. So, we would have a a conversation
of non-conensual consensual on a
Are you kidding me? And he admits it. This is him talking. >> Listen,
this could be bad.
Yeah, I describe it. You cannot do that. Uh that was I don't
think that is possible. I'm pretty sure that you could just write
notes. But the transcript will be on Monday. Isn't this insane?
Is this actually insane that he's like, "Oh yeah, like we didn't
do consensual, non-consensual. I would convince her that she's
wrong by having a whiteboard if we weren't seeing eye to eye.
You got a whiteboard to try to convince her that she is wrong
on consensual non-con?" Why do you need to have an argument about
this? Why is there a conversation? And if there is, you don't
need a whiteboard. You would bring it out all the time. You were
so You had so many times you had a problem and a disagreement
with it that you would have to bring out a whiteboard. You know
what coercive control is, right? Yes. And you told her that she
has memory problems, right?
I believe we had discussions on her memory not being as sharp
as it is. I'm sure we've had conversations about memory aids
and because you believe that her memory recollection because
of what she's saying now is false and incorrect.
Do I believe her current memory is incorrect? Yes. Is that what
you're saying? So she would he would literally tell this girl
that she has memory problems and that's the issue. He has memory
problems and would sit her down with a whiteboard trying to tell
her that she is wrong when it comes to consensual non-consentual.
You want to know why? Because she would grab her face and have
her suck his dick. >> He would grab her face and have her
suck his dick. And you want to know why he wasn't having with
her? Cuz he's a
>> Oh, I'm seeing where this is going. And because he did
the same things, he would say the same degrading created his
wife in the same way. >> Because Emily went live and said
her that's how you make the connections story is that I went
to her house after we started dating again.
>> She brought me to her place. We didn't live together.
Her place we started making out for like 30 minutes and I put
my hand down because I thought that that's where we were going
next. She yelled. I get up and left. That's
worth four days of YouTube videos and ruining my life, right?
That's worth four days of YouTube videos and ruining my life,
making people think I'm a when I go on the street. But this isn't,
right? This isn't a whiteboard to convince her. This is psychotic
[__] This is psychotic. It's disgusting. It's not
over, by the way. There is so much more. This is literally part
one. Okay, this is part one. And okay, your ex-wife made some
pretty awful allegations against you, didn't she? Abuse and assault.
She did, but she didn't know they were lying.
Well, now remember, Teone, you have an NDA. It's in the court
order. Okay. But you have some pretty serious allegations she
made against you, Tech. Mhm.
And so, you learned from that marriage that what can happen with
false allegations. Well, not false. I don't know if they were
true or not, but you knew how to handle allegations like that
from your first marriage. Correct? So, this is the lawyer talking.
Tecton said, "I don't think I handle those problems pretty well.
I think I handled those pretty bad." So Techto admits that in
Frame's marriage, he handled things pretty poorly and he did
a terrible job. >> Dude, I am the conflict. >> But
you definitely knew how to handle it when you had my client in
your house, right? That is such a great question because it shows
that Techone didn't care to learn from his mistakes after being
vile to to Free and he went right to Pinku. Pingchu to do it
next.
Well, I'm telling you this. How many times did you go to her
and ask for her medications?
Did you tell her and tell her what things to tell her parents
to prescribe for certain medications?
I wanted to make sense of what was going on in her head and she
wanted it. I would try to help her and say, "Well, maybe this
is it." And tell her what she should get. I would definitely
try to help her with her medications.
>> Oh, what? I >> And what pharmaceutical background
do you have to be giving medications? I definitely do not have
any background, but you couldn't help yourself with your own.
Yes, I've had horrible experiences with my medications. Oh, Misc's
going to not know that Tekone's schizophrenic. I think this is
not going to have no idea. >> He literally admits that
he doesn't like and take his own medication. He couldn't help
himself with his own, but he would tell her what to get medication
wise. He said says, "What kind of pharmaceutical background do
you have to be giving this medications?" None. And he would draw
on the whiteboard to tell her what and why she's wrong on consensual
non-consensual. because he would apparently he had this problem
so many times that he would need to constantly bring out a whiteboard
to describe it. You know what he has chat that he says that he
has schizophrenia
schizophrenia. And he doesn't take his medication because he
doesn't like it. He doesn't like it. He's pretending and acting
like or saying he has whatever it is schizophrenia and he doesn't
take his own medication cuz he doesn't like how it makes him
feel. But he forces her to go to her mom to buy uh medication
for him herself.
there more. Oh my god, there's more. >> Moore said in the
courtroom over seven hours. These are just the highlights chat.
The rest will be on Monday and Tuesday. Ready? This is crazy.
He used OTK power saying he could get her deals with mythic talent.
He said, and I quote, "It would be good for me to have a hot
cosplay girl living in the house." >> Oh,
dude. Oh, that's not good, man. Oh, that's really bad. Do it.
Just in terms of being a big streamer using like your >> said
all she had to do to live there for free is edit pictures and
thumbnails and it then turned into suck my for free rent. I felt
disgusted he treated me like a [__] machine. She
claimed it he made her degrade herself and if you uh do this
we'll have a normal relationship trying to make her sign an NDA
but refused. She tried playing uh paying rent
because she said, "You don't pay rent, get to work." Basically
saying, "You don't pay rent, suck my
It became the point that she felt [__] were an obligation.
During that time, she got her done and she said she couldn't
do anything, but he became upset and unruly. So, one day, he
grabbed her head by the shoulders and put his her face by his
crotch and started off, told her to open up.
Apparently, he would record her without her permission while
he made her satisfy him and threatened to leak it. >> Want
to know what happened, chat? The court, the judge ordered Teone
at the end of the sentencing after 8 hours that any of the things
that he had on his phone were so bad that he is ordered to delete
them, otherwise he will be tried for criminal uh uh uh investigation.
And is that true, Axian?
>> Yes, it is. >> He claimed on stream he was a streamer.
Apparently, he would record her without permission while he made
her satisfying threat to leak it. He claimed on stream he was
a streamer with a [__] machine. He did say that.
He called her the most forward woman he's ever met. In quotes,
called her a he has schizophrenia would say, "I see your face
just melting." So, a lot of this court case apparently next,
and you can tell me if I'm wrong, he would go and say that that
he has schizophrenia and that's why uh a lot of this is happening
and he would blame it on schizophrenia.
And he wouldn't take his medications for it, chat, because he
didn't like the way it made him feel,
but he would make her take medications. Not only make her take
medications, would tell her what to prescribe and de and get
and would tell her mom to go get it. >> Dude, what the
is being said here? >> Indicated he was called a after
her tweet. Her tweet never mentioned him by name. Uh he tweeted
her name
>> it on stream. >> It's really not anything.
I I'm >> I'm not going to go back and check. >> This
is a quote after showing a few small tweets of him being there
second could have possibly got Oh, >> so remember what
I told you guys chat when I said that claimed he did so much
due diligence in so much of his time was spent getting all the
information. How I told you how important it is that if you're
in a court case, you should probably have people sending you
things and helping you that you should probably be putting your
due diligence into it,
I said that. You spent 15 minutes
This is a quote after showing a few small tweets of being called
names. Pulled last second tweets. Could have probably got more.
I only spent 15 >> I got you the soundboard, Missy. Okay.
>> Tech has been in this court case and and been involved
in this for almost two years. He spent 15 minutes getting
>> He did no due diligence for his own
>> because he probably has nothing that would offend him.
lawyer replied and this is Pinku's lawyer. We've been in deposition
for over what seven nine months and the only spent 15 minutes
searching for tweets. Tech's response and I quote, "Yes, >> that's
very bizarre.
15 minutes, man.
Really? 15 minutes?"
>> He defended his rants, which is the things going on
where he goes and attacks people and constantly berades Pingchu
and everyone else. When a content creator in our space gets these
accusations, they have to pivot content to stay relevant. He's
basically saying the reason why he went to right-wing politics
and started attacking Assan is because twice as long as he lasts
in bed >> because it's because he needs to because otherwise
he would be irrelevant.
>> That's pretty crazy. The grip. Then the best part, he
brought up Hassan Abby saying like how when he shocked his dog,
he literally admitted that he had to switch his content and go
after creators like Hassan Abby
uh shocking his dog in
>> He actually brought it up too. That is >> dude.
[laughter]
I was like, "What the is this?
>> What is wrong with this guy, dude?
What do you know about Hassan [__] >> They
talked about a lot about how he would use to record her without
her permission and how he would threaten to leak those as if
as the big nukes if she didn't recite recede her claims about
him. The judge said he better delete all videos and pictures
that he has of her and the judge was angry as after hearing it
all. She was furious apparently.
So in conclusion after 7 hours of things and we were going to
go over the transcripts by the way on Monday or Tuesday whenever
we can grab them. The judge claimed that they found sufficient
evidence to think that he did commit assault. So, normally he
would stop there, right? That would be the end of it. Uh, civil
court, maybe he has to pay the legal fees, call it a day. No,
no, no, no. It was so bad that the judge made him delete all
video and evidence and every picture he had of things that he
took when she didn't want it, of times that he grabbed her and
forced her to suck his times that he made her do things she didn't
want to do, and times that she didn't want to be recorded. >> Reading
a little bit in there. judge said, "Delete everything about Pingchu
on your phone or I'm going to try you for criminal charges."
>> That he is ordered to remove and delete and get rid
of all pictures and videos without her permission and even with
or he will face criminal charges. He is forced to pay her attorney
fees around $50,000. The protective order is for 10 years, chat.
You I don't think a lot of you understand how crazy it is to
get a protective order. That means that when Tekon goes on planes,
he has to do something that it's going to follow Tecton for the
next 10 years of his life. It is serious.
>> It is serious.
>> And he can't own guns. He can't own any type of weapon
in his house. They're all going to get seized. He can't have
any of it. >> He can't talk about her or any time can uh
can talk about her on stream. He can't own guns and ammunition.
He must stay at least 200 yards away from her. And if they happen
to be in the same place at the same time by accident, he must
leave immediately. He cannot contact her, talk about her, or
have other people talk about her,
Oh, that's that's the shot right there.
Rape to when when rape becomes tone. Okay. It's not good. It's
not good. How insane was all of this? >> We got another
dance party. M. Insane was all this. >> It's pretty crazy.
>> And this is just the >> transcript, but it's pretty
crazy. >> Still more in the transcripts.
>> We We're going to go back and try to Rosetta Stone together
whatever the first part was. >> Guy came after me. >> The
cross there. >> This guy came after me for years. This
guy came after so many creators for years. This guy attacked
so many people for years. >> And this is who he was.
A disgusting bile human being. More. Yeah. What's the point?
Does it really need to be more with all this? Does there really
need to be more than this? This is insane. She would literally
be like, "Hey, like that's not consensual. I don't like it."
And stop recording me. >> I need to I probably need the
>> You can see by the chart, uh, Pink that you're now come
here. Like he would [laughter] literally That's what he would
do. Hit a white board. They had so many arguments to prove that
she's wrong. He would then tell her that you have bad memory
loss and that's why you think you're right. You're wrong because
you have a bad memory. Oh, pink. I think that you have such bad
stuff going on in your head that you need to get prescribed stuff.
I'm gonna tell you what to tell your mom to go get here. This
go get this. This is what you need. And he literally admits that
he doesn't have a prescription or pharmaceutical background in
the slightest, but he would tell her what to go get. And he put
a lot of the blame apparently on schizophrenia. There is apparently
an accident, you can tell me if I'm wrong, allegedly one time
where he literally admitted that he almost Jimmy here in a car
because he said he saw something. >> He said he saw somebody
behind him talking to him and he almost crashed the car.
It's that bad. His schizophrenia. >> So this guy's schizophrenia
is that bad where he's almost people, harassing people, and being
abusive. And when he's asked to why doesn't he take his medication,
he says he doesn't like how it makes him feel. >> Absolutely
wild. I would like to thank all of you for coming to my small
little uh retreat tonight. The rest will be on transcripts on
Monday and Tuesday when when we get them. Enjoy the weekend and
you should watch
this. Your favorite creator as well, man. Okay.
>> Go see that doctor.
>> Not a little doctor, but go on your date, buddy. Go
on your day, buddy. >> Big shout out to Axian here for
going to court and and writing a lot of this. There is still
more to come. The
that ever pulls up tech on the stream. found that he was so disgusting
he might be tried for criminal charges. >> Rehab accept
skitsos. >> I would love to see how anyone defends this
and I would love to see your favorite content creators not talk
about this because I will use that in court. They won't talk
about it. You want to know why? Because techone has on them and
they're afraid. That's exactly it. He has on them. Lucari has
on them and they're afraid to [__] talk. That's exactly
what it is. It's not that they're friends. It's not that they're
hanging out. It's they're afraid. They're terrified that Lucari
or Techone [laughter] has some more [__] on them
and they're terrified about it. So the people that stick their
nose in everything, the drama frogs that constantly attack everybody,
why are you staying silent? Why aren't you talking about such
a crazy criminal
Why do you hide that I what I said yesterday and think that what
I said was why are you still not bringing it up when I have literal
receipts it yesterday? These are
full court some of them. Teone is not just bad. He's vile. And
the people that have been hanging out with him for years are
disgusting. You're all gross. Anyone that's messaged Teeone in
years, you're disgusting because it's not been unknown that Te's
a disgusting piece of We've all known it. I haven't liked Teone
in years. I thought he's a disgusting human being. >> But
you all hang out with him and treat him like he's okay. You message
him and stuff when you're not supposed to. Why? >> Why
do you
when he got outed for being weird? >> Let's go. Why do
you message him after he got out of for his dad yet? You want
to do play believe all victims. You want to play the cards that
you're actually a good person and that you care about anything
about assault or anything like that.
Yeah, right. You don't care about it at all. You don't care about
the victims. You care about nobody beside your ego and yourself
and you're mad that I dated this girl. You're mad that I lived
in this world. You're mad that I'm still around. I'm not going
anywhere. I promise you that. >> I'm not going anywhere.
I'm tired of not standing up for myself and I'm tired that I
I let these run my life. Techone talked [__] about
me for a year and a half. Year and a half. He just ruined my
reputation. Talks about my community. Made people question who
I am after I've worked 8 to 10 years of my life giving it up
for this job and he tries to take this away from me. >> Worst
of all and Tech's big response today was it's cold outside. >> Okay.
You know, if someone accused me of this crime of all and lied
like this
says, you know, I probably would say, "Misk's a massive liar
and I'm going to sue him and I'm going to go live to talk about
this." And you just said it's >> Who's pink, you ask? >> Why
are you talking about just a second >> Interesting, huh?
>> But just in case you a single word. >> Why is
your friend saying a sing? Okay. Also pink.
>> This is also pink. >> Why will none of people
in your circle speak about this?
What do you have on them? >> Somebody sent me a bunch of
like pictures to do this. If you're not
about because you know what happens when they don't talk about
you? It makes them look like a hypocrite because they talked
about my my my problems. They talked about my issues >> and
they literally made me ruin my life again. They ruined my >> Oh,
needs to apologize for some reason. They won't talk about you
>> and I can't wait to apologize. >> Talk about you
talk about me. Makes no sense. Makes zero [laughter] sense. Oh.
Uh, I don't want to talk about Lucari. He was a friend of mine.
Okay. Uh, I don't want to talk about TechTome. Why'd you talk
about Miz? He's in your org. I'm confused. Makes no sense.
It makes no sense.
It's only reason is you wanted to take me down. That's it. Melena
was always right. Techone. Absolutely. There's not a single LSF
thread about any of your coverage. >> What? That's impossible.
There's no way. This is not possible. That's not possible. That's
not possible. There's no way. >> Clips from days after
Pink went public.
Okay, chat, prove that you didn't sneeze 10 seconds ago. Prove
it. The problem is is that if I do this, then every other victim,
every other person who's been accused coming after me might face
negative repercussions by them saying, "Well, tech don't provided
proof of something that he didn't do." And once again, I absolutely
could. I absolutely could. But Pink, I said this over and over
again that he could prove it of these horrendous things I did.
And I have a feeling you will not show any of it. The fact that
you were trying to paint me as a
is insane.
>> It's absolutely insane.
>> As of yet, Pink hasn't said anything on the Twitter
X base, but if she releases anything, I'll be sure to let you
guys know in another video. But Asmin Gold SP >> Did he
Did he show the judge this video? What did the judge think about
this video when he said he could definitely prove it? What did
the judge think, man? >> If you're someone that has a following
and a Twitter,
>> join my everybody spamming that tweet, please. Let the
world know the truth of Tech. Don't let this get hidden. Don't
let this get hit taken away.
>> Don't let it because these big streamers don't want
to talk about it that Tech gets away with this. Don't let it
>> The doctor is waiting.
>> The doctor is waiting. He's actually late for the doctor.
>> Even the judge at the end said there was sufficient
evidence
that I believe you committed what she said you did. >> Let's
go. >> You committed assault.
boke out on the situation between Teone and Pink in the following
clip. >> Commenting on the Techone drama. Um,
>> Had three of my friends. Uh, actually >> We'll
see what happens. If we got some Misrogs in here by accusations
that >> I'm thinking we could just do a little bit more
Tech content tonight and get back to the Minnesota shooting tomorrow.
>> Give me a second. We could easily do
>> Yeah, that's going to my lawyer. >> Okay, hold
on. I'm tired of having people accuse people that I know of something
of a crime >> and they expect me to
>> they expect me to removing this person out of their
life, >> but they won't even commit to seeking
>> They want me to be justice. I'm not >> What about
stale? Oh, we've got the stale, too. >> Throughout my streaming
career, we all know who it is. We all Everybody knows who it
is. And at the end of the day, I am I am so tired of having to
pretend like this is some kind of evil thing. >> I'm putting
this back in the chat again.
I am not an investigator.
You do not have jurisdiction over this. Expect me to excommunicate
or to remove a person from my life based off of accusations that
are unproven. And you did not even try to go to the police. Get
the
out of here.
>> Ironic because she never went to the police. Very ironic.
Asmin Gold. She never went to the police for 10 months and she
still hasn't gone to the police a year later. Interesting. Wow.
It's almost like exactly what you did to me is what you say you
would never do here.
Wow.
I would love to see his response to this. I would love to see
his response to this. That is
insane.
That is insane. >> Dude, Misk be getting one guy like crazy.
It is demon time though. Okay, this is demon time. >> This
is literally what happened. Like this is literally what happened.
Yo, Joe, bro, what did you think of this? What happened?
>> I was good. I'm psyched for those transcripts, man.
Psyched for those >> Joe, bro, what did you think of this?
>> What happened? >> Very excited for Monday. It's
going to be good. >> I was good. I'm psyched for those
transcripts, man. Bro, >> for those trans
what what is chat,
manuch for a second.
>> I cannot believe Asmin said this. That is insane. >> Like
I'm going to play it again just to show how insane that is. I
I I mean like he literally is textbook
just attacked me only. He just attacked me and no one
>> X base. But if she releases anything, I'll be sure to
let you guys know in another video. But Asmin Gold spoke out
on the situation between Teone and Pink in the following clip.
>> Commenting on the Techone drama.
>> I mean, I've got >> Teone gets accused of assault.
>> Oh my goodness. >> And and uh the girl he grabbed
her face and would put it towards his
that were not >> you sorry. I meant to go to the nothing
ever happens getting assassinated. Okay. I'm telling >> this
guy's going down in the big 26. Okay, we're taking this guy out.
>> We're taking him out. We're taking him >> Me too.
>> His argument is going to be that I when too many jump
there. Jesus Christ, right? That's what he's going to say. Okay.
What about Fe?
What about Fe then
Is that enough of a line for you? That two women that he was
very close to, one went out and had this issue, the other one
had another issue. Is that not it? Is that not enough? >> They
expect me to commit to removing this person out of their life.
>> But they won't even commit to
>> 7662. Thank you for the gifted zone. >> They want
me to be just I'm not Batman. >> I have uh I've not added
time onto the stream. I've not caught up with that. We >> We've
got the whole stream. Okay. >> I've not added more time.
I could just remove the clock. I might just let it go to zero.
>> All right. We've got way more time tonight. We've got
way more time to cook. We can do all kinds of All right. This
is some kind of evil. >> But all the lines of people that
M is close to >> all the lines of I don't know what you
mean. She's beef. I am not an investigative authority. I do not
have jurisdiction over this. >> Okay. Is this guy going
to go
to a person love demon time?
>> I get why he's gold. I get it.
>> Get the out of here. >> Stick a move, man. Stick
a move. He didn't take the He's still raped tone. He hasn't evolved
yet. Okay, he hasn't evolved. He's still raped tone. All right,
where are we going?
Is this the It's cold outside tweet.
No,
hold on. Hold on. Looking looking. It is the cold cold out tweet.
Yeah, >> the only thing was taken on at a minutes with
400, >> dude. It's [__] It's actually insane.
>> It's insane how
>> There's no way that's the Dude, there's no way. Okay,
we've got a new one. criminal charges possible for techone.
>> But that's not But that's not even that's like saying
if he doesn't delete. >> Do you not see what you're doing
here? >> Non-conensually recorded stuff that she's claiming
he had.
>> And you're Let's see what the comments >> What
are the comments like the Bel Deline one? Yeah. Hold on. Can
I Can we get a comment on the Bel Deline DMs there, Miss Kip?
>> A shot with Bel Deline and talking to Mike from PA.
Okay. If it makes you feel better, she messaged me.
Mike from PA? Really? Wait, what's wrong with Mike from PA?
Is he a bad dude or something? >> I'm pretty sure. Also,
Mike from PA just asked him a question. >> He's pretty
bad. Oh, I just saw that he said he hates techone.
>> I I I I don't know, Chad. I I >> That's the only
thing we care about. >> I had no idea he's a bad guy or
not. I I don't I literally do not know him. >> Dude, it's
so gay when people are It's just so gay when people go and do
the This guy really sucks. You shouldn't talk to this guy.
>> How long until this post finish is like the first one?
Four hours.
Why does it m Why does this need to be up there? I just literally
exposed that Techone insulted and abused people and your one
thing that you have on there is that I leaked my Twitter DMs.
>> I'm glad. >> Which literally is nothing? Like,
who gives a >> How do I put this?
>> I do know that. So, from Mike's DM, if you looked at
Mike's DM,
>> if you look at Mike's DM, he's saying, "Hey, Mskip,
how do you know this? Hey, Msk, how do you know this?" Right?
That's I don't care about any of this, by the way. Um,
so Mike and Msk heard this from different sources or that source
is both of their source. Okay? I've heard this from a third person.
the the idea that Miz sent his guy the guy wrote stuff down and
we've got like the main details like that he was found liable
for this assault that he owes her her attorney's fees that he
is 10 years without a gun. The idea that any of these details
would be independently replicated multiple times across multiple
different sources seems very unlikely to me. So even if you don't
like that Msk's transcripts there were let's be honest they weren't
the best. Okay, I think you get a general picture, but they weren't
Like I I think I understand. We might go play Rosetta Stone with
those and try to figure out precisely what was getting said there
because it is a little difficult. I can't tell if they're talking
specifically about CNC or what
>> he didn't respond to Mike from PA. It's Dude, it's whatever.
>> DM'd you.
>> Nice.
Man,
>> you Axian Axian wants to know
>> Rosetta Stone. Yeah, like trying to put together what's
actually being said there likely. >> cuz it feels like
>> I get the information, but
>> yeah, it would be hard without a laptop. Tacitim, you're
not wrong.
There is a follow
because techone attack and LSF hasn't >> I love this song
hasn't my opinion this is a song I never heard this is like my
favorite song I'm actually allowed to say that you can postf
all you want about me from >> paralyzer
they they told me to say that
>> hold on the
marble stream she cares
Oh [screaming] no.
[laughter]
>> How about you try playing with consentual partners instead?
>> This post will age very poorly. Smiley >> I also
want to show one more thing before I go. >> No way. No
way. No way.
>> No way.
>> Mythic talent has terminated the relationship with Techtome.
Says the process was initiated several months ago and finalized
recently. I don't really care if that's true or not,
>> but they got rid of me. >> The [__]
>> All right, Axian, I'm gonna go. Hey, Axen, you go live.
Go live. >> Wait, no gambling? >> No, I got to I
have a date right now. I can do gambling later when I get back.
I'll just do an hour stream. >> Listen, if Axian gets the
raid, Axen's got to get the raid for going to the
>> He's got to get He's got to get the the >> He
went to Austin. He covered the
>> not. All right,
>> wait a minute. So this whole time act techone was pretending
to be a doctor when in reality I'm dating one. Maybe that's why
he was so jealous of me. >> Total Teone
Destruction stream. >> All right, boys. >> I'm going
to do a $200 giveaway right now for chat for new people here.
>> Do it
here that uh you've heard these allegations and things about
me and I hope it makes you think twice. I really
>> I really watch the the Tech followup video, guys. Okay.
And then we've got Sale 10 as well. So, we'll probably do both
of these at minimum. >> I don't know what to tell you more.
>> I do want to see the stale content.
>> I'm very excited. We might do humanizing. I'll see.
I'll see where we're going to go for sure. Okay. But I might
do humanizing. >> Uh, say the word yo. Oh, wait. Where
is >> Guys, just another thing. If you're new to our community,
discord.gg/jstlk.
All right. If you want to be a part of the community that makes
these memes, that looks into these issues, okay? Is way ahead
of the curve. We know exactly who's going down on the internet
6 months ahead of time all the time. Okay, you want to be a part
of this community?
All right, thank you everybody for being here. I'm going to grab
a drink about watching my streams because of people and lying
and using my content >> and abusing
his family with them, abusing their community to make me look
bad when literally every accusation against me
>> every single one. And they ruined my life over it. Where
I go to parties, I go to events and I get kicked out. where I
get called a when I go to bars.
>> And guess what? They won't talk about techone. They
won't do it.
>> You'll talk about every single thing in the world, but
you won't talk about
>> You even admitted that you don't want to talk about
stuff on stream like this. Uh because it's bad, but you'll talk
about
>> I You can't hide from talking about TechT. Cuz if you
don't talk about Tech and your community's connected to him,
guess what? You're supporting him in my >> because you're
supporting the fact that he has these allegations that are >> We
got to get in with Miskf so that we can help him understand.
Okay. >> Proven in the court. >> We need we need
to help him understand that he's got to move on with his life.
That he can't hate the people who accuse him of stuff that that
will leave him bitter and he won't be able to make good content.
Okay, we will convince him of this. All right, we will help him
move
>> Burn the boats.
>> Only forward. Okay, no going back. No looking at the
past. Who gives a about the past? It's in the rear view except
>> and then bro got [__] >> for revenge.
All right.
He's grifting.
All right. First >> purpose. It's not bro anything. >> Baldi
one techone then Baldi too. Okay. >> What time are you
going to continue on >> I will continue when I get the
transcripts. That is the next thing that we will go over. >> All right.
He's going. But I will say
>> in the past few days, I think a lot of people have the
truth about me. >> And they realize the truth about others
around me >> and they realize that more is coming
>> This is just the beginning, chat. I'll tell you that
right now. >> No, I'm streaming tomorrow. I'm streaming
tonight when I get back. I have to do the gambling. >> Oh,
yeah. He could No, no, no, no, no. >> I'll I'll come back
after the date and I can talk about it. >> When I say Yeah.
>> When I say you should move on, I don't mean from Asmin
Gold, okay? I don't mean from that. >> I appreciate you,
chat. >> I appreciate all of you. >> Love you. Thank
you guys for listening to me. >> Please spread the word.
Spread the word and let everyone know the truth of this file
human being that has with my life and many others for years.
Please spread the word about someone that has lied about the
fact that he said he doesn't know about his father. >> He
lied
and even if he had an abusive father that held a gun to his head
and he brought him around his friends and tried to prop him up
on stream. He's a disgusting human being.
>> What a piece of
>> W stream.
Okay, I'm going to have to get out of this here. >> Remember
when people say I view bot? Oh, interesting. I have 800 people
that participate in the $200 giveaway. Chad, if it gets to a
thousand, we'll do a $400 giveaway. We'll do two 200s and then
I got to go. I got three. I got five minutes.
>> Get it, give me less than three.
>> Yo yo, I'll get in this giveaway. Yo yo, throw me in
that giveaway. I'll get in that giveaway. >> I'm very
cont.
Let's go.
And if they don't, it's just more ammo for me in court. I was
wrong about you. Will talk about
>> I understand that when your content creator funnels
lies and non-stop, it's easy to believe. >> Isn't it state
cash? I'll take 400 bucks in state cash, >> especially
if you trust them for their
>> I won't be spending it on stream, but yeah, I take it.
I'd take it, man. >> I would say wait till the transcript's
out for its proof.
>> You think I just made all this up? >> Do you think
I made all this up?
Do you think I just lied?
>> Like, come on, bro.
Do you think I I I caught him gle,
>> dude. If I win, I'm going to tell him to keep the uh
>> keep the money and just send me the playlist. Okay,
let me get that playlist from you. >> And that he has a
a protective order on >> It's it's out there.
>> We apologize. >> We're not doing it stream. >> I'm
not perfect and neither are you.
>> You don't need to apologize. >> Love this guy.
>> I understand. >> As much as I've enjoyed this
moment where I get to like reboot somebody else's content and
do very little work, >> I do believe it's time for me to
once again pick up the mantle of live stream I used to be friends
with who used uh who who lied about >> that time where
I picked the mantle back up and I actually start doing the work
and carrying the stream myself and or >> reacted to videos
myself. Okay, >> I have I have theories why it's about
that time. I have my theories
>> and I'm sure you do too.
>> E won't stop talking about
>> Hold on. >> Yo, your DMs got leaked on LSF. I
can care less.
My DMs aren't bad. >> His DMs were nothing bad. Yeah. Yeah.
>> You see what they're talking about? They're like, "Dude,
he's messaging some guy from 4chan getting evidence and
I literally sent him my lawyer to and said send everything here.
>> He's messaging Bella Deline.
>> Okay. And Mike from PA where I just literally said hi.
I have no idea who he even is.
>> Stop saying couldn't care less.
>> I'm trying to tweet again. >> And Twitter just
broke on me.
>> Jesus Christ.
Whole browser froze there for a second.
I I find it embarrassing and disgusting that that's what they're
talking about when I know a lot of them are watching my stream
right now. I know a lot of them have seen what I just brought
to the table and shown. And instead of trying to attack Teone
and let people know the truth about him, LSF is more focused
on the fact that I'm messaging a guy with a girl with a Bella
Delphine and Mike from PA.
>> Are you going to tweet out who's next? No. I don't think
you understand when I say that demon time is something that is
it's not a a it's not a thing that will happen today, tomorrow,
a week, a month. It's whenever it's ready.
>> And I think people on TikTok who have a brain of a peanut
and and a lot of LSF and all around think that when I said demon
time, it means I'm going to go on kick and immediately start
attacking everyone and destroying everyone. That's not the case.
It's not even what I want to do. >> Well, that would have
been what I want to do. I don't want to ruin people's lives.
That would have been awesome. did anything to me and didn't get
a tweet >> I'm not here to just bash everybody and take
everyone to the ground. That's not how I roll. >> What
I'm doing is I'm going after people that have been bad to me
when they have way worse things about them. >> I literally
can't LSF for posting a clip, bro. No shot.
New regime not doing so good, man. >> LSF is actually protecting
Techone. No, they're not.
>> No, they're not.
Sorry, I'm letting I'm letting this cook for a second with the
music because I
>> having issues. One second.
Post this guy. Okay.
Somebody somebody went, you know, made it even better. All >> And
it's techone. [music] >> Somebody went went made it way
better. All right. >> I got banned, too. What?
>> wait. Really? Why are they deleting the post about TechTone
>> and uploading an irrelevant clip about
>> Guess what? They're finding out tomorrow. You're a loser.
>> This is >> and I can't >> This is weird,
man. >> There we go. >> This is weird.
>> Appropriate time. He's done. He's done though, guys.
He's gone.
TONE IS OUT OF HERE. HE'S out of here.
It's the police.
>> Hello. Who's at the door? Open up, >> He's so
He's so funny. This guy is so
into a room and says, >> "Hold on. I'm uh I can't hear
the voice. The voice is actually
Sorry, dude." Dude, dude, dude, dude. I can't get my tweet out.
Hold on. Back turned up. >> Hey, Maple, you want? He has
a point, but he never salted emer. But she farmed it that way.
Now I'll take my downs from a fanfan to keep defending tectone.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.